cardi B announces she and offset have
split together anymore the 26 year old
rapper shared the news Tuesday night to
posting this video to Instagram I've
been trying to work things out with my
baby father for how many now and we're
really good friends and you know we're
really good business partners and you
know he's always somebody that I went to
to talk to and we got a lot of love for
each other but things just haven't been
working out between us for a long time
and it's nobody's fault it's just like I
guess we're out of love but we're not
together anymore I don't know it might
take time to get a divorce and I'm gonna
always have a lot of love for him
because he is my daughter's father and
yes the former couple welcomed their
first child together a daughter named
culture on July 10th when et spoke with
cardi November she praised offset as a
wonderful hands-on father but what is
offset like as a dad I mean is he
changing diapers he is changing diapers
but like I've been seeing offset being a
dad he already has three kids so I
already fell in love the way they he was
a dad already I'm like oh my god I could
have a little one with this guy he's
really good he's really good you guys
want more are you talking about that
yeah I certainly want more how many more
I want two more are you guys working on
that right now
mmm I mean it could be always ahead of
MS but I don't want none right now
cardian offset tied the knot in a secret
ceremony in September 2017 a month
before the me goes rapper proposed with
a giant ring onstage the pair managed to
keep their nuptials under wraps till
June 2018 when cardi revealed the news
on Twitter
you